Одеський будинок профспілок.
Він розташований у центрі міста, але справляє
враження забутого Богом і людьми місця.
Три роки тому тут загинули 48 людей.
Вони згоріли, задихнулись або розбились,
кидаючись із вікон палаючого будинку.
Декого - застрелили.
На паркані будівлі - тимчасовий меморіал
зі списком їхніх імен.
Вадиму Папурі було лише 17 років,
коли він загинув - наймолодша жертва.
Його матір Фатіма щонеділі
приходить на могилу сина.
"Ми пишаємось тобою" -
викарбувано на його надгробній плиті.
Фатіма не була в центрі міста з того часу,
як її єдиний син загинув.
Розумієте, будинок профспілок для мене
- це просто...
місце, де... накопочилось
дуже багато горя,
смерті, страждання, болю.
Увечері другого травня 2014 року
коктейлі Молотова полетіли у Будинок профспілок.
Проросійські демонстранти знайшли собі там сховище.
Туди за ними гналися прихильники Майдану.
Перед цим дві групи конфлікту декілька годин
брутально з'ясовували стосунки на вулиці.
Вадим Папура був на проросійському боці.
Мати досі зберігає його каску,
яка деформувалася від жару вогню в будинку профспілок.
Ось серп і молот...
це його "Червоний легіон".
Як я знаю, що це його каска? Він незадовго до цього підписав її.
Там було ще багато таких касок.
Батьки Вадима нічого не змінювали в кімнаті сина.
Вадим приєднався до комсомолу при Компартії України,
нині забороненій,
і виступав проти уряду в Києві та його проєвропейського напрямку.
Перші загиблі були членами проєвропейського руху.
Їх застрелили під час вуличної бійки сепаратисти.
Тетяна Сойкіна була на проєвропейському боці і
навіть сьогодні їй не дуже шкода тих,
хто був на проросійському боці
і загинув у будівлі профспілок.
Дуже багато агресії накопичилося.
Вже не було нічого шкода.
Я розумію, що там люди були,
можливо, навіть
не самі винні,
але це були люди, які
розхитували ситуацію в Одесі і які хотіли тут Росію,
які хотіли тут війни.
Це, по суті, ворог.
Україна була на межі громадянської війни.
Одеська трагедія стала передвісником
кривавих подій на Донбасі.
Незалежний комітет місцевих жителів документував
події другого травня, аби допомогти офіційному слідству,
яке досі не дало жодних результатів.
Я абсолютно не виправдовую наших слідчих,
але варто сказати, що справа дійсно дуже важка.
Ну, і плюс, звісно,
до цього додається наша винятково українська специфіка,
пов'язана з непрофесійністю.
Рада Європи та ООН нарікають на те,
що українська влада затягнула з розслідуванням.
Поліція це звинувачення заперечує.
Як має працювати правосуддя
в країні, де йде війна і де немає верховенства права?
Повинне бути якесь правове поле, в межах якого
можна проводити слідчі дії.
Коли країна опинилася на порозі війни, коли в Одесі відбувались ці події,
тоді навіть не йшлося про верховенство права.
Парк Перемоги в Одесі - одне з улюблених місць Вадима Папури.
Останнім часом Фатіма часто сюди приходить.
Рідні інших жертв Одеської трагедії подали
позов проти України до Європейського суду з прав людини.
Фатіма не подала, але вона хоче,
аби ситуація нарешті прояснилась.
Тут справа в якості розслідування.
Тобто… ви ж розумієте, що коли все це робиться швидко-швидко,
дуже часто страждають люди, які в цьому не винні.
Знайдуть якогось цапа-відбувайла.
Тут важлива не швидкість, хоча три роки -
це дуже довго.
Щороку на річницю трагедії ситуація в Одесі накаляється.
Цього року поліція тримає ситуацію під контролем.
Але прихильники і прозахідного, і проросійського руху
ставлять ті ж самі запитання.
Чи були тоді вказівки зверху - робити провокації
чи це була спонтанна ескалація насильства,
яка спричинила трагедію?
Чи можна було її зупинити?
Одного дня відповіді на деякі з цих питань
будуть знайдені за слідами трагедії у Будинку профспілок.